uh do a lap without me i need to talk to
larry about an issue with our shared
fence larry i need to talk to you about
an issue with our shared fence yes i
also need to discuss this shared fence
issue with you okay they're out of
earshot why are you up so early no
reason just excited to face a new day oh
because ever since we've been down here
you've been a little
depressed
have i
no
don't eat the burrito
[Music]
okay fine i may have had a teensy bit of
trouble adjusting when we first got here
for like six teensy little months but i
took your advice and i got a job doing
what i sell atvs now huh well the truth
is these little babies sell themselves
they're super fun and they're a lot
safer than you might think if you're
standing next to one if you're driving
it it's actually much more dangerous
than you could possibly imagine
ah captain you're at my desk
just what i want to see first thing in
the morning you're three minutes late
peralta not my fault i had a plumbing
problem
[Music]
which reminds me i'm gonna need a new
departmentally issued phone
oh come on really i'm a few minutes late
so you're gonna call me out in front of
everyone good idea
everyone gather round so i can call out
peralta in front of you okay fine
i was three minutes late i'm sorry for
doing one thing wrong oh it's more than
one thing
let's start with the kristoff murder
there's an amazing solve i got him to
confess in 20 minutes you also
mislabeled the evidence so that
confession is worthless if the sergeant
hadn't caught your mistake here are
three cases with sloppy paperwork here
are two pictures
one is your locker the other is a
garbage dump in the philippines can you
tell which is which
that one's the dump they're both your
locker ah i should have guessed that
he's good this folder is labeled
undies comma dirty so i won't confuse it
with undies comma clean also who cares
about all these rules i have more felony
arrests than any other detective here
you also have more mice living in your
desk than any other detective
algernon
you guys algernon's back get rid of the
mouse and get your act together now
he's grumpy apparently my husband kevin
has invited you all to my party there's
very little street parking no gifts no
singing of happy birthday should be fun
sounds fantastic
did you hear that
his husband invited us not him he so
doesn't want us there yes he does it was
kind of a last-minute invite
just stir in the pot why wouldn't holt
want us there because he thinks we're
going to embarrass him in front of his
husband which frankly is insulting oh
man all the orange soda spilled out of
my cereal i've been chasing this guy for
three months i've got him dead to rights
fingerprints witnesses it's in the bag
so i'm just gonna grab a healthy
breakfast are those gummy bears wrapped
in a fruit roll-up
breakfast burrito but yeah i pity your
dentist ah joke's on you i don't have a
dentist
my grandpa was an old-school cop this
was his hangover cure
raw egg yolks
you look like a corpse we just pulled
out of the river wrong i look like a
cool rock star who od'd in his own pool
big difference i told you not to let
jimmy broken distract you from your work
so i assume you're not too hungover to
do said work
nope it's like i never even drank and
that's not a hangover cure what that no
it's just some
protein
for my guns i drink one every morning
before i lift
so
so good
you can barely even tell it's a chicken
embryo
you should drink it all
for your guns
[Music]
it's like fitness right
hey buddy what you doing i'm just
cleaning up my desk trying not to think
about how freddy got away oh i didn't
let anyone touch anything while you were
gone and that was a mistake i left food
everywhere this drawer is completely
full of maggots now booze wanna get a
drink nope i think i'm just gonna stay
here and stare into the maggot drawer
hey that's a good name for a death metal
song staring to the maggot draw
you want to talk about it my death metal
album sure all right just finish taking
off your totally ineffective biohazard
suits and have a little rest nonsense
santiago we just have to buckle down and
work harder we simply hit a bump in the
road more like a mump
in the road
such a good one
jay can i talk to you in private for a
minute sure thing let me just snag this
cover up the old swell sack
all right okay so here's the deal i have
a high fever and i can't control my body
but you can do whatever you want to me
oh but don't touch my mouth neck or
testicles
you've badly misread the situation oh
thank god okay we're all set up in there
mr peralta just uh sign here what's all
set up what's going on ah thank you for
asking terrence you see
the food in prison was inedible all i
thought about day and night were the
things i wished i was eating and you amy
i thought about you a lot sex with you
just us doing sex with foreplay great
safe babe thanks and so i decided to
make my food fantasy come true unbutton
your pants and take off your shoes cause
there's gonna be a doink load of sodium
at freedom feast 2017. we begin where
all great stories begin in the quaint
little town a french fry village after
that we're gonna move our adventure over
to cheeseburger mountain which consists
you guessed it of turkey burgers i'm
kidding it's cheeseburgers this is kind
of just stuffing you can avoid that but
it's attached to the thanksgiving turkey
theme cause i was thinking about that a
lot up in the jail and finally we have a
big old passover brisket cause you know
i loves my mom if you would all take a
seat while i make a toast
kindly raise your two liters
to freedom to you and most importantly
to orange frank
and sex with amy to sex with amy sorry
should have said that last part
i made the saddle out of your sister now
i'm gonna put it on your back
and your sister and i are gonna trot you
all around the apartment what's wrong
with you i'm jake peralta the grossest
pervert of all time
my petey you're under arrest you
unbelievable creep you never take me
alive
[Music]
rotten hell jake peralta
[Music]
they use my name
you